نقلت وكاله عن المسؤولين محليين في منطقه
بيرياسكا الروسيه قولهم ان مدنيين اثنين
قتلا في قصف اوكراني استهدف احدى القرى في
المنطقه من جهتها
مقتل شخصين واصابه اربعه نتيجه قصف
اوكراني استهدف مدينه
شرقي اوكرانيا
معنا مراسل الجزيره تامر الصمادي ومن
موسكو مراسل الجزيره بابا ولد حرمه ابدا
معك تامر صماد عندما يتكلم قائد
فاجنر ويقول تقدمنا بمسافه مئه الى 150
متر هذا يعكس الى حد كبير حجم ما يجري من
معارك وصعوبه التقدم حتى يتم الحديث عن
امتار كنوع من الانتصار وتحقيق تقدم ماذا
عن اخر المعلومات يتعلق ومختلف الجبهات
تامر
بالفعل تتحدث القوات الاوكرانيه تحديدا
هيئه الاركان الاوكرانيه عبد القادر عن
التطورات في باخموت على مدار الساعه لكنها
تحتفظ بنفس الروايه بنفس المعلومات تقول
بان القوات الاوكرانيه ما زالت تقاتل ما
زالت تسيطر على مواقعها في باق موت وتتحدث
وتقر بان المعارك شرسه وشرسه للغايه وان
الوضع صعب هناك لكنها تقول بانها تعمل على
صد هجمات متتاليه للقوات الروسيه ويوم امس
تحدثت عن هجوم للقوات الروسيه وصفته
بالفاشل على محور بخموت صباح هذا اليوم
ايضا في البيان الصباحي تحدثت هيئه
الاركان عن صد قواتها لاكثر من 50 هجوما
للقوات الروسيه باتجاهات بخموت وابديفكا
ومارينكا
وايمان وقالت بان القتال يتواصل هناك على
اكثر من محور وذهبت الى ابعد من ذلك في
الحقيقه عبد القادر هي عندما قالت بان
الاخفاقات المتتاليه ما سمتها بالاخفاقات
المتتاليه للقوات الروسيه على الارض في
اشاره الى المعارك التي تدور بينها وبين
تلك القوات دفعت الجيش الروسي الى تكثيف
الغارات الجويه استخدام الغارات الجويه
على بخموت وعلى الاتجاهات الاخرى في
المناطق الشرقيه في
الدومباس لكن في الحقيقه عبد القادر القصف
ايضا الروسي يتواصل في هذه الاثناء على
العديد من المقاطعات الجنوبيه نتحدث هنا
عن نيكولايف حيث نقف منذ ساعات الصباح
وعمده المقاطعه
والعديد من المسؤولين السياسيين
والعسكريين هنا يتحدثون عن قصف روسي
متواصل للمواقع الساحليه لسيمه تشوك اوف
كوستروب وايضا المواقع التي تتركز فيها
البنيه التحتيه الحديث عن خطوط الماء
والكهرباء وفي الحقيقه القصف الاعنف
والمتبادل بين القوات الاوكرانيه والروسيه
يج في القرب من هنا من مقاطعه خيرسون التي
باتت مقاطعه مغلقه بقرار من الاداره
العسكريه الاوكرانيه قبل قليل ظهرت
المتحدثه باسم قياده عمليات الجنوب
الاوكراني على التلفزيون الرسمي وقالت بان
القصف الاوكراني لا يتوقف على طول الضفه
الشرقيه من نهر دنيبر في خرسون التي
تتواجد فيها القوات الروسيه خلال الايام
الماضيه تتحدث عن تتحدثت عن الاستمرار في
تطهير تلك المواقع على حد وصفها اليوم
تقول بان القوات الروسيه المتواجده في
خيرسون لم تعد امنه وبان القصف الاوكراني
بمختلف انواع الذخيره لا يهدا لا يتوقف
لكن في المقابل عبد القادر تحدث حاكم
خرسون الاوكراني خلال ساعات الصباح عن
اكثر من 100 هجوم بمختلف انواع الذخيره
ايضا من قبل القوات الروسيه على عموم
اراضي المقاطعه تحدث عن قتيلين وعن عدد من
الجرحى وهو نفسه الذي يوم امس وقال بان
القوات الاوكرانيه ستعمل على تجهيز طرق
للاخلاء اخلاء من تبقى من سكان في خرسون
وذلك على واقع الهجوم المضاد غير المعلن
كما يقال هنا في اوكرانيا او في الجنوب
الاوكراني الذي تقوم به القوات الاوكرانيه
على خيرسون ايضا القصف والقصف المتبادل
يتواصل في جبروجيا جنوبا وكانت السلطات
سلطات المدينه الاوكرانيه تحدثت ايضا خلال
ساعات الصباح عن اكثر من 70 هجوما نفذته
القوات الروسيه على عديد القرى الواقعه
على طول خطوط التماس وتحدثت عن استهداف
البنيه التحتيه لكن عبد القادر نهايه
الحديث ايضا لا يتوقف اوكرانيا عما جرى في
سيفاستوبل يوم امس في شبه جزيره القرم وفي
الاشاره الى استهداف مستودع النفط كما
تقول السلطات الاوكرانيه ايضا قياده
عمليات الجنوب قبل قليل فقط من الان تحدثت
عن حاله من الكبيره في اوساط الروس
والمتعاولين معهم في شبه جزيره القرم وعن
خشيه روسيه من عدم نجاح المضادات
والدفاعات الروسيه في حمايه المنشات
الاستراتيجيه النفطيه لا سيما فيل وفي شبه
جزيره القرم و تحدثت ايضا الناطقه او
المتحدثه باسم قياده عمليات الجنوب على
التلفزيون الرسمي ايضا في تعليقها على ما
جرب الامس وقالت بان المعلومات
الاستخباريه الاوكرانيه تشير الى حاله من
النزوح لعائلات العسكريين الروس
المتواجدين في شبه جزيره القرم تتحدث عن
نزوح جماعي في هذه الاثناء وهذا الحديث
جاء فقط بعد ساعات قليله من
تصريحات لمديريه المخابرات العامه
الاوكرانيه التي قالت بان شبه جزيره القرم
سوف تظل مستهدفه بالقوه الناريه
الاوكرانيه لاسيما المناطق الحساسه
والاستراتيجيه والعسكريه وذهبت مديريه
المخابرات الاوكرانيه الابعد من ذلك عندما
قالت
بان اودعت السكان المحليين الى الابتعاد
عن الاماكن الحساسه والعسكريه هناك وقالت
بان الاستهداف الذي تعرض له مستودع النفط
المذكور كان يغذي اسطول البحر الاسود
التابع للقوات الروسيه الذي كما تقول
السلطات الاوكرانيه يعمد بشكل مستمر على
استهداف المدن الاوكرانيه لاسيما في جنوب
اوكرانيا ايضا كانت هنالك خلال الساعات
الماضيه تصريحات وحديث في الخطاب المسائي
للرئيس زيلينسكي الذي قال بان الهجوم
المضاد يجري الاستعداد له بشكل واضح ومكثف
من قبل الاوكرانيه وبان على سلم اولويات
هذا الهجوم هو شبه جزيره القرم واستعاده
كامل الاراضي التي التي عفوا تسيطر عليها
القوات الروسيه لكنه حتى المجتمع الدولي
حلفاء اوكرانيا على ارسال المزيد من
المساعدات العسكريه المطلوبه وقال بان هذه
المساعدات معروفه بالنسبه للشركاء للحلفاء
وبان التوقيت على غايه من الاهميه وعلى
غايه من الحساسيه في هذا الراهن كما قال